let's talk about Rocket Man again it is
all the rage here in the UK but last
night the cast will doubt their silver
carpet for the New York premiere a
yellow brick road you might say I'm here
all week rocking a denim jacket he kept
from the movie star Taron Egerton says
he is fiercely proud of the film that's
already getting Oscar buzz I think it's
incredibly flattering I can't think
about it though if I think about it
I can't think about it rami malek knows
a little something about that he hit up
last night's after party to support
Terrance that's real friendship
especially considering Elton John
famously dis brownie for lip-syncing in
Bohemian Rhapsody but no awkward run-ins
here Elton missed the premiere because
he was performing in Italy still Elton
was deeply hands-on in the production of
Rocket Man personally approving each
costume and the cast would be Elizabeth
the first
[Music]
I am Elton John being oh probably have
to do one of his watches because they
are pretty stunning you'd kind of see
towering wedding watches the Elton
actually wore back there and I can look
and there's two bodyguards are like
stealing took your hand down I suppose I
mean it would be quite fun to have that
Donald Duck outfit
you can make you could make some sort of
you could make some sort of installation
with that so I got it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]